How's it going everybody. It's your friendly neighborhood, Dave Rubin.
You normally see me wandering the mean streets of Los Angeles with my dog.
But today I am in the swamp.
I am in Washington, DC,
the most wretched hive of scum and villainy.
And I am here wandering around first off. It's a complete ghost town.
There are no other humans here. I'm in a zombie movie with nose homies.
That's what it feels like. It's like, we, it,
it has the eerie feeling of a zombie movie. And yet the zombies,
I guess there's a little sun out. So this armies aren't coming outside.
So I'm basically in, I am legend right now. I'm will Smith and I need a dog.
I really do need a dog. There's there's there's cracks in the street.
Plenty of cracks in the street in this dystopia. All right, well,
I am with another human here. All right. We got a thousand people and I am here.
Morning, ladies and gentlemen, with my agent slash bodyguard.
The pre pubescent service agents.
[Inaudible] my secret service agent. He's keeping me safe on the main streets.
I will be shocked if you see another human in this video,
there's nobody anywhere. Kyle.
If you don't wear a mask outside, you'll be shot. You know,
these are the rules. How it's her tank comes up and blast you off.
Sometimes you go to jail.
There's nobody here. We could run DC. You think Trump's even at the white house.
I feel like we could just walk in.
No doors taking your seventh nap of the day in Calabasas at the moment.
She's not here.
Unbelievable. If you want to tell the people about your mere math problem.
Yes. So Kyle's got an.
Issue with masks. You know, everyone, the mass thing I walked in,
I went into an office and I did have to put a mask on, um,
I considered robbing them at gunpoint, but then at the last second,
I say that I'll just go to.
So my mask is not as bougie as it's not the fight. My issue.
I've never had acne as a kid. Never, never.
And now it's popping over everywhere.
Adult acne. That's one of the side effects of this thing. You know what I mean?
People talk about the side effects of COVID, but they're not.
Nobody talks about the side effects of my face, breaking out. Now,
obviously COVID is real, you know, but you know, this is, I can't wear makeup.
I can't, I don't know how to put on makeup. Right?
So the question is,
do you want to shut down the world economy forever and usher in a new world
order and have acne at the same time.
And then Amazon is going to send you the skin supplies to like fix my face.
And now this, this is the roundabout. Yeah.
Anyway, as you can see, we have not seen another human being. There's nobody.
There's nobody. There's.
There's one woman across the way we still are in DC or lobbyists and they're
defective zombies.
Oh, wait. I'm almost gotten to get into, Oh, there's a car.
There's a car with a man. All right. Very.
Exciting. Yeah.
We're trying to find a place to eat. We're starving.
Everything's closed a lot of things. Boarded up. I just like a Turkey sandwich.
Just to, could I get a Turkey sandwich or wrap? Maybe a salad. Nothing is open.
Nothing. There's nothing, but we're we're out here. Cause it looks,
listen, look at this. It literally, it looks.
Everyday. We're fighting the good fight out here in DC. Okay. Every day. No,
we can't cross. We'll get run over. Listen, we're here fighting corruption.
I'm here fighting skin acne. I do a lot for the people,
for the American people and people don't respect that.
People don't appreciate the full extent my audience respects it for what I do
for us.
Anyway. So, um, I'm in DC for about 24 hours. Uh,
this afternoon, I'm going to the white house Hanukah party.
We're going to celebrate eight crazy nights. Uh,
of those pesky Jews survive in the green.
If I post a photo that looks like champagne, it's not champagne. It's wine.
Yes. Yes. If I post a picture or a video drinking champagne,
it most likely is champagne. Um, so yeah, we're, we're heading,
we're heading to the white house in a little bit. Um,
I actually just this morning I was just sitting, having coffee at the,
at the Trump hotel.
And I bumped into judge Jeanine who I've done her show a million times,
but we'd actually never met in person. So it's kind of fun when you know,
we're going to a real restaurant, if there's a real restaurant. Um,
but it's fun when you actually meet these people in real life, you know,
because I, I think for, for you guys too, you just see,
you see all this, how's it going, man? How are you going? All right. See, good.
We saw real people. We've been trying to find real people.
You guys are real human beings. I'm not I'm on Periscope right now.
Is that cool? Yeah. So real finally, we were trying to find real people in DC.
We couldn't find any, you guys are real humans, humanoids in any way,
real people. Can you believe it? Incredibly cool.
It's good to meet you guys take it easy. Real people,
real Rubin report people. That's what I'm talking about, man.
People in DC and we found it. All right. That was incredible. Did he see,
I touched the guy. Do I have to disinfect my hand now?
I probably shouldn't say that publicly. Yeah.
It was just, no, I mean now the FBI and CIA are on your.
This is how it goes to jail.
This is it, people. This is it. All right. So, so yeah.
So I saw judgey Dean this morning and it's nice when you see like actual people.
I think one of the things happening right now is we don't see human beings
anymore. And if you do see human room, good food, right?
If they're wearing a hat like this and we've got glasses like this,
and now I understand why Kylo Ren took off the mask every now and again,
you know.
I'm not there yet on the star Wars episodes. So I haven't seen it.
I'm working off I'm on episode six and five.
You didn't watch your budget. Let's not get killed here. Look at this.
There's nobody.
Anywhere. No.
Buddy. There's a couple of cars. I don't know where they're going.
They're all fleeing. Oh, by the way, if you see that little,
little scar on my forehead, I was going to a,
to a rally in Los Angeles the other day to, to rail against this woman,
Sheila Kool who's, one of the city supervisors who shut down all the,
all the outdoor meals, all the outdoor reading.
And then she went for an outdoor meal. She literally voted on it.
This woman who makes $300,000 a year to do Jack,
she voted to close all the outdoor restaurants.
And then she went to an outdoor restaurant.
Cause she knew she had like a 24 hour window before they all closed down.
People are major hypocrites.
Or something that they know that we don't like.
They don't actually believe their own rules as well. None of it.
No people they're middle-management morons who can't produce.
So they want to control other people that that's it. But anyway,
so I go to this, I'm on the way to the rally to protest this woman.
And we got clipped on the four Oh five. And uh, when I,
when I pulled over, when I pulled over.
Telling you his,
he got into a fight with Gavin Newsome and he doesn't want to say it publicly.
They had an MMA match. It was paper for you.
I've been thinking about challenging them. They've won.
I would challenge Newsome where Garcetti to a duel,
like maybe that's where this is all headed. You know what I mean?
Like we'll just have to have public duals now. Like good to sure.
You've closed down the old,
the restaurants while you rocking up $15,000 Booz bills at French laundry,
I challenge you to do.
I would pay for this. People.
Would pay for that. It's the only way. Anyway. I hope we see it was nice.
At least that the only people we saw knew me,
but where it's everybody like,
is everyone just stuck at home? Someone said, my body guard looks high.
No, I look hi. I'm actually not. I'm not.
No, no he's not high. Actually.
You want to know a little insider information about us? Twitter.
People were like Twitter. People were going to the white house.
Kyle forgot socks. Well, not forgot socks. He only had like ankle high socks.
Sorry. I didn't want to repeat. I bought them. I only had these socks,
socks record. I was willing to pay for it. Dave, Oxford generously.
Happy holidays. Uh,
and I forgot my belt and you can't go to the white house without a belt.
So we went to H and M and we got the fanciest socks and belts.
There is nobody here. I mean, I'm not, when I tell you this, I am not kidding.
There is, there is not a human.
I can literally run around naked in the street.
It's Chile shrinkage. But like,
there is no buddy here. Yeah. Here's the guy here's,
there's icy woman. We're about to pass a man in a little bit.
He obviously is a government agent.
Hold on, let me, I don't want to.
Speak too loudly. He's obvious this guy is up to no good.
Hold on. Hold on. He's not wearing a mask. Hold on, hold on.
All right. You see him that, that was shady. I mean,
this is how you destroyed your country.
Yeah. This is how you destroy a country. I mean, everything is shut down.
I love DC by the way, you know, I,
I joke about the swamp and everything else and politics and all of that,
but DC, DC, you know? So where,
w what part of town are we in right now? And we're basically in Capitol Hill,
right? So we're right by the national mall. Um,
so the Capitol building is that, is that,
so that's the Capitol building right there. Here. We'll, we'll, we'll walk that.
I mean, there's just nobody here. You can't even go. I try to get my brother,
uh, toward, you can't even go into the Senate unless like, you can't,
you can't go inside. Where's the, where's the Jefferson Memorial.
I know it's a little off the, off the beat. You know what, maybe,
maybe I'll do like a, something in a little bit. I got,
I got like two hours here. Uh,
maybe I'll do something from the Jefferson Memorial because it's not in the main
path that all the memorials, you know,
people think people think of the Lincoln Memorial, the,
obviously the Washington monument,
but the Jefferson Memorial really is wonderful.
And they have some of his writing, uh, etched in the wall.
And it's really quite amazing.
Do you know what any of these other buildings are? As long as we're here?
I mean, these are government bureaucracy everywhere, but that's here.
That's the Capitol. So you can see it.
That's the Capitol building right there. That's funny.
Someone made a good point. I've got my bodyguard with me,
but there's no other people out here. Yeah. Up there.
Somebody doing construction, that's good.
Or they're building the underground bunkers, I suppose. All right.
We're going to grab some lunch. Uh,
I assume the people you're allowed to eat that that's illegal. Figure it out.
I feel like I'm in a reservoir dogs right now.
This guy is this mad max. All right, I'm going to go eat something.
And then maybe we'll, uh,
we'll wander over to the Jefferson Memorial or something else.
And I'll try to do something from the white house later. We'll see.
We'll see what happens. But anyway, man, it's weird. It's weird.
This isn't how people are supposed to live. You're supposed to live free.
You're supposed to wander around and have a little risk in life.
See other humans. Oh God.
I had to be a radical revolutionary.
I just want it to be a sports center anchor. You know that that's the truth.
I just want it to be a sports center anchor. And now I got to save the Republic.
What a headache in the NBA now he's doing well in Washington, DC,
trying to say I know. I know. All right guys. Thanks everybody.
We'll check in later.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.